foreign
[Music]
what do we have here yeah here I thought
we were special fellas this here's Bag
Man hang man whatever what the heck on
the mission is this
[Music]
the best there is who the hell are they
gonna get to teach us
Captain p eat Maverick Mitchell let me
be perfectly blocked you are not my
first choice you were here at the
request of Admiral kazanski AKA Iceman
he seems to think that you have
something left to offer the Navy
what that is I can't imagine
it's all due respect sir I'm not a
teacher just want to manage expectations
good morning aviators
this is your captain speaking
and we're off
we're going into combat on a level no
living Pilots ever seen not even him if
you think up there you're dead believe
me
my dad believed in you
I'm not gonna make the same mistake
[Music]
you'll never forgive yourself
no turning back now come on
[Music]
having any fun yet
[Music]
Bruce Wayne
sorry I wouldn't be bothering you here
but your people keep telling me you're
unavailable
the family has a history of philanthropy
but as far as I can tell you're not
doing anything
[Music]
foreign
to you
there's latest it's all about the
Wayne's if we don't stand up no one will
you got a lot of cats never think about
strikes
the cat and the cat
your new friend of yours
I'm not so sure
I'm just here to unmask the truth about
this Cesspool we call a city you're part
of this tool
oh my part of this
oh you're really not a smart
proves away
all these years been lied to me
we all have our scars Bruce you're still
away
he's involved in this oh he's not
involved how do you know except for
Delaney who are you under there what are
you hiding Selena don't throw your life
away don't worry honey I got nine of
them
oh
it can be cruel poetic or blind
foreign
[Music]
Mrs Wang are you with us I am paying
attention
now you may only see a pile of receipts
but I see a story
see where this story is going
it does not look good
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
to help you
watch the Multiverse
is a great evil but it's like the many
verses
and you
maybe your only chance of stopping it
don't make me fight you I am really good
I don't believe you
almost really good
he's waiting in the wings the universe
he speaks of Senseless things
from all the places I could be
remember our mission concerning the
faith of every single world of our
infinite Multiverse
there is no way I am the Evelyn you are
looking for
free rejection every disappointment has
led you here
this moment
don't let anything distract you from it
[Music]
[Music]
why do you want to hunt
because you all think that I can't
I saw a sign in the sky
I'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
there's something out there I'm coming
with you
can't I'm trying to protect you protect
me from what
[Music]
it's time
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
I know how to survive
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
only the most broken people
can be great leaders
[Music]
they called him
the feather serpent Court
killing him
slow risk Eternal War
[Music]
we know what you whisper
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
what if I told you
that today
you'll leave here
I'm talking
to
you
bro what'd you see summon above the
clouds that's big I'll be big
you think whatever kill pops is out
there
right here
you are gonna witness an absolute
spectacle
[Music]
so what happens next
are you ready
[Music]
here we go
this will be an opportunity I'm talking
rich and famous for life there's plenty
of videos for flying [ __ ]
onlineable proof of aliens on camera the
open shot see you guys want to tell me
what's going on hell no
cause I'm out here you're the only
person in the world that can get it on
field
a cloud pay more than that it's aliens
they're just waiting for the perfect
time to shove metal probes up our asses
I'll be rooting for you
I think we pissed them off yeah they
repainted your house
they're gonna come back
you ready
we got some work to do not it nope
let's go baby let's go
I need y'all to tell me what did you see
in that cloud
it's not what you think
they took them all
I'm trying to save you my brother is out
there
thank you
if you don't look at it
we end up at the top of the mountain
it's the one you never wake up from
you'll be getting a call from my
supervisor asking how my service was
five stars Angel five stars
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but I feel her
I hear her heartbeat
[Music]
she's so close
what does her heartbeat sound like
[Music]
mighty
[Music]
[Music]
we cannot let you bring your War here
outcast
that's all they see
I see you
way of water connects all things
before your birth
and after your death
this is our home
I need you to be strong
[Music]
heart
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
s signify the commitment
Hey Thomas sorry sorry life or death
situation I need you to use the ring to
save me like right now
ah Hawaii I just hope we are not too
late oh Lord there are two of them now
what's happening okay quick version
Robotnik is back
I discovered the source of ultimate
power
we need to get it back before the world
is Doom
you rock some kind of
space porcupine I am an Echidna Warrior
hmm
Hedgehog It's Time to Say Goodbye to
humanity
welcome to the new Norm
this is your moment to be the big hero
bad time to say this but I don't
actually have a plan
hey you got a little something on your
uh someone call an Uber
cold in here
let's turn up the heat
oh great the Winter Soldier
fear not citizens you are terrible at
this your negative attitude is not
helping
untrained
unworthy
you forgot one
Unstoppable
[Music]
for a guy named Knuckles you are really
bad at punching
foreign
[Music]
for a bartender aren't you a little old
for prom aren't you
[Music]
everything in here why the map it's the
biggest treasure that's never been found
five billion easy but it's just a story
I beg to differ
[Music]
500 years ago
my family found the world's biggest
Fortune then was betrayed
people have been searching for it all in
vain what was the attorney he's
clockwise at the same time
thanks a lot he almost got me killed
clockwise Sully oh it was 50 50 so I
made a guess clearly
foliage was not just about gold it was
something much more valuable this girls
has a very tragic history so much blood
I'm pretty sure he's just threatened to
kill me
oh this is gonna suck
don't get caught
you were just gonna leave me back there
somebody had to get the cross
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
you have no idea who you partnered with
what else aren't you telling me the
Victor spoils
how are they gonna get them out of here
thank you
foreign
[Music]
what is that thing on your face
puberty's right around the corner kids
you can grow your own
exclusively in movie theaters
foreign
[Music]
this isn't funny Amber what do you like
to play
diplier
[Laughter]
doors unlocked
all doors locked
doors unlocked
hello it's happening three attacks so
far do you have a gun I'm in Sydney and
Prescott of course I have a gun
something about this one just feels
different
Samantha
I Know Who You Are I've been through
this a lot
this is your life now which means that
whoever this is is Gonna Keep Coming For
You
[Music]
you ready
for this
there's certain rules to surviving
Good Times we're all on people related
to the original killers
[Applause]
whatever his link is to our past
it's pulled us all back here
until he's in the ground
[Music]
it's an honor
um
[Music]
[Music]
oh yes please
peanut
peanuts
all right
[Music]
listening
[Music]
no no
[Music]
no no
[Music]
every night
I dreamed the same dream
the nightmare begins
I did what I had to do
[Music]
protect our world you cannot control
everything strange
you open the doorway between universes
and we don't know whom or what will vote
for it
want that what do you know about the
Multiverse it is had his theories
he believed it was dangerous
he was right
I'm sorry Stephen
the desecration of reality
will not go unpunished
[Music]
we should tell him the truth
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I do it I become the enemy
[Music]
it doesn't seem fair
[Music]
blue had a baby that's impossible
hey girl you look just like your mother
[Music]
I promise you I am gonna get her back
genetic power has not been Unleashed
we've made a terrible mistake
the Doomsday Clock might be about out of
time
if our world's gonna survive matters is
what we do now I can use your expertise
you coming or what
a baby Raptor I made a promise we would
bring her home you made a promise to a
dinosaur yeah why
thank you
everybody hold on to somebody
what's that biggest carnivore the world
has ever seen
run
see not so bad
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hi I know you're nervous I just want to
have a chat
I'm seeing something no one else can see
except for me it's smiling at me
[Music]
yesterday a patient in your care died
brutally in front of you
[Music]
I need to find an explanation for what
happened
smiling at me
smiling at me
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
I found 20 cases involving 19 victims
with the direct line linking them all
together
[Applause]
you said only 19.
why is it that everybody else who's seen
it just dead in your life
I've seen it
yeah
[Music]
how long between each victim's death
none of them survived longer than a week
today is my fourth day I am not gonna
keep running
face it how does that make you feel
come on
[Music]
I'm just really scared that something
bad is going to happen
Rose
[Applause]
[Music]
Carl I don't know what you think you're
doing excuse me hello
get a dead white man in a box
not even a cat
up on it in a pine box of old wood what
do you think's gonna get in trouble here
[Music]
favor try to be optimistic
you don't get here without things
starting a long time ago
[Music]
so two soldiers and a nurse found
ourselves in Amsterdam
we formed the pact and we swore to
protect each other no matter what
we find ourselves in a situation where
we're accused of killing someone which
is not true
Ewan Woodman fled the scene the killer
pointed at us we didn't do anything why
would you possibly think that was us
well there's not too many people that
fit the description of a doctor looking
for his eye on the ground with his black
Attorney Columbia Law School
find the truth my friend was killed
because of something monstrous that he
had seen
this is all turning out to be a lot
larger than any of us
you're gonna have to take my lead
getting out of this one I had to stab a
guy I had to hit a lady with a brick one
time what it's a long story but with
Youtube it'll be a cakewalk
she's a dangerous times you be careful
I'm about to do something that could
cost me my life
the cuckoo is in the nest and the
Cuckoo's about to be trapped
cuckoo
[Music]
this is one of the finest Innovations
from Zurich it removes all pain
guys like me we have to turn their bows
the morphine and that can lead to
addiction oh that's fast that is
advantage
[Music]
Black Adam
what have your powers ever given to you
nothing but heartache
I was a slave until I died
then I was reborn to God
my son sacrificed his life to save me
[Music]
in this world
they're Heroes
Heroes don't kill people
well I do
my vision has shown me the future
you have two choices you can be the
destroyer of this world
or you can be its savior
that's up to you
thank you
foreign
[Music]
am I right
this is gonna be the best year ever if
nothing's gonna get in my way
[Music]
breakfast is ready
[Music]
It's Gonna be Me
is everything okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this happened already what did you say
our ancestors had a mystical connection
with red pandas are you kidding me this
little Quirk writes me in our family
you were so cute sick I've always wanted
a tail I'm a freak we love you may
you're our girl
whoa you're you
any strong emotions release the panda
Abby hit me
[Music]
oh
do you know how dangerous this is you'll
get whipped up into a frenzy and Panda
all over
OMG
my whole life have been perfect little
Maymay but maybe I like this new me
Mama's girls
foreign
makeup
sorry what
I just said you don't even need to wear
makeup
all right
what's that
did you know anyone who died
I don't want it all over no good for you
can I have some wine
did you have like the craziest
nightmares last night you have to be
able to sleep to have nightmares
tell me about your brother he was
making money
you went through something no one should
ever have to go through
you stay just till I fall asleep
it's [ __ ] hard I'm sorry we're saying
[ __ ] no you're right life's [ __ ]
hard god well try it it feels good life
[ __ ] confusing I
what are you thinking about I can't say
it let's say you die tomorrow now what
if you die sad because you regret not
saying what you want to say
[Music]
this can't be for nothing we won't even
let this be for nothing
[Music]
the shoulders you can't do it without
the shoulders
[Music]
Fate has no mercy
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
I think what we have here in Hollywood
is higher
High art it's
[Applause]
where'd you go
I always wanted to be part of something
bigger yes yes let's go
something that lasts that means
something
[Applause]
[Music]
you know when I first moved yeah
you know what shines on all the doors
read no actors or dogs allowed
I changed that good morning good job for
you I'll do anything that's the jackass
they said to screw us
[Applause]
[Music]
her nipples so they perk up through our
dress I ain't ice in my nipples this is
natural
and for my close-up now
what are your thoughts for the future
shouldn't stand in the way of progress
because it's gonna be what it's gonna be
twist
the girl seems nice she is she has no
idea what's next
there's a nuisance ability right now
people care about Morris
I've never done nothing to disappoint
people my whole life
I made it on my terms not theirs
[Music]
we are going to be more than they ever
bargained for
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Deer Creek International Business
Solutions how can I help you I am ready
well that's great ladybug ladybug your
new operational name oh I see what
you're doing ladybug's supposed to be
lucky
you don't have bad luck really
my bad luck is biblical I'm not even
trying to kill people and someone dies I
remember the suicidal billboard you
drove him to the hospital
[Music]
Johannesburg it's time for some change
do you want it simple for your first job
back doesn't get simpler
we need to find a person through that
case
[Music]
it's too easy
[ __ ] what remember those two wackos from
oblivious the twins yeah and I'll show
you their twins get off the train
[Music]
you stabbed me
what
I missed my stop something else going on
here hi
you don't remember me you look like
every white homeless man I've ever seen
really you don't remember me
[Music]
thanks lady I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm I'm
working on it get off at the next time
it's so sweet easy when you say it one
little pregnant so you know what happens
yes your blood congeals
you're going to want to hear the whole
story it's waiting for us from Kyoto the
white death with his army of Assassins
there's this solar psychotic leader with
the largest criminal organization on the
planet shop right inside
see the white death let in any of us off
this train
we need to come up with a plan
into your face maybe there was a little
head trauma Maybe
[Music]
it's
strange
[Music]
sorry buddy
exclusively in movie theaters
we are gathered here today to say
goodbye to [ __ ] much
you are down to your last life
oh
brother cats sister kitties meet your
new roommates well
I'm supposed to be a Fearless hero a
legend this is a person party that's
your party so this is
[Applause]
what let's talk
I don't speak Spanish either
funny uh what's your
what's my story
what are we looking at cats have nine
lives what what
I think you said they have been too high
now I am on my last laugh oh no
Legend tell us
waiting to be granted
I need your help is the great posing
boots asking for help well you see yeah
okay please that wish look at me my
life's back okay okay pause on face I
won't make you back but first foreign
nothing should be funny
everyone is looking for a Wishing Star
I'm going to wish for everything to be
just right
[Music]
you will find your reward does not come
easily Puss in Boots Goldie there's all
right let's get it over here
[Music]
without life despair I am nothing when
you only have one life that's what makes
it special go get him tiger hey take it
easy
it's gonna be fun
[Music]
is in the dark Forest we step through as
one ready one two after you wait what
dog
still alive let's go find out
all right
kids get to popcorn now let me tell you
the story of the space Viking Thor
odenson he was no ordinary man he was a
God
after saving planet Earth for the 500th
time Thor set off on a New Journey well
he got in shape
he went from dead Bob
the god bird
and after all that he reclaimed his
title
as the one and only four
oh speak to you soon Jane
[Music]
the old ex-girlfriend
what's your family three four years
eight years seven months and six days
give or take
am I uh sensing feelings
[Music]
are you all right
the only ones who Gods care about
is themselves
so This Is My Vow
oh God shall die
I was gonna say that was very very
impressive what you did back there
[Music]
you never forget your first
[Music]
kill
because I have something worth fighting
for
[Music]
let's see who you are I take off your
disguise
oh you flick too hard damn it
should we help them and eventually grape
[Music]
you led me straight to the lost city now
prepare to die there are just hundreds
of snakes in this Temple just waiting
for us to show up what why aren't they
biting that guy this is ridiculous
delete delete
oh
listen Loretta we need you to promote
your new book on the lost city you can't
spend your life in the bathtub drink
Chardonnay with eyes
ladies and gentlemen the world's sexiest
cover model
you do know you're not Dash right dash
is a character I made up oh my God
oh crap
message I enjoyed your book about the
lost city and I believe you're the one
who can help me find its treasure
I have to respectfully decline I'm
afraid I must insist
on chain me that's your seatbelt
Loretta Sage is missing I'm gonna rescue
her I just want her to think of me as
more than a cover mouth
Allen what are you doing here we're here
savings I'm a certified CPR I'm
certified CrossFit I have snacks after
that
we're on the love more and dash
Adventure right now I'm gonna help you
out a little bit let's go what are you
doing don't do that come on get out of
there this is not a romance novel
jungles eat people like us
I can feel them suckers
who's gonna make that sound it looks
like there's more holy mother of God ah
there's a sucking on my butt like a big
old Jamba Juice
we're so close I could actually find the
lost city
if I don't get to this island my friend
and her cover bottles are going to die I
am driving oh
oh oh
Loretta Sage getting you out of here why
are you so handsome my dad was the
weatherman hey well she doesn't need
saving in there uh what are you doing in
there
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
everyone easily 12 customers total how
do they turn the profit 12.50 ahead
that's how what are we eating a Rolex
classics
you have to try the mouse feel of the
minionette please don't say mouthful
tonight will be Madness
welcome
we'll Endeavor to make your evening as
pleasant as possible
[Music]
welcome to Hawthorne
Here We are family
we Harvest we ferment we gel
wait gel we gel
he's not just a chef he's a storyteller
game he's trying to guess what the
overarching theme of the entire meal is
going to be you won't know until the end
who are you I am Marga
how do you care I have to know if you're
with us or with them
this menu the pictures
how do they get these it's not good this
entire evening
Jesus Christ is just theater it's stage
crowd we're leaving now has been
painstakingly planned
this is really heavy what the hell is
going on
we now offer you a 45 second Head Start
okay 45 seconds Starts Now
this is what you're paying for
you
it's all part of the menu
no we're gonna die today
[Music]
you told them it was my birthday seemed
funny about three hours ago
on the outside
the five of you are villains Predators
remorse of the sociopaths
I'll stop you're making me flash
we're the bad guys and this is the crew
Mr Snake Serpentine safe cracking
machine magic Houdini but with no arms
jackpot yes Miss tarantula our in-house
Tech wizard where'd you learn to do that
mostly YouTube Mr piranha he's Brave
crazy
what's up Bubba and Mr shark Master of
Disguise his greatest trick stealing the
Mona Lisa disguise as the Mona Lisa and
rounding out the crew is me the big bad
wolf we may be bad but we're so good at
it all right then we're out of here
well this just got a little weird
no wolf
oh if only we were given a chance to be
anything more than criminals if you want
to stay out of jail you need to go good
what are you doing we're gonna pretend
to go good the bad guys become the good
guys so we can stay in the band guys
it's fantastic you're a genius
welcome to the first day of the rest of
your best life [ __ ] it's a cat stuck in
a tree what does your heart tell you to
do a good person would smack it
yeah
I want you to save it
we're more than just scary villains they
love us you're such a good boy
a bad guy no no no
will always be bad guys
let's try something simpler I'm going to
give you a push pop just for me no to
share this is gonna taste extra sweet
nope suckers
I'm totally worth it
[Music]
okay
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's been four years since Michael Myers
vanished Without a Trace
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Music]
I was certain but I saw him
watching me
you pretend like you moved on but you're
actually just obsessed with death what
are you gonna do when Michael comes back
for you because he is coming
but this time
something feels different
he's more dangerous
thank you
[Music]
he killed my daughter but tonight I will
kill him come and get me
boys
[Music]
maybe the only way he can die is if I
die too
it all ends now
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome
Whitney Houston
[Applause]
a common criticism of you your music
isn't black enough what who said that
that's just Bull and it makes me angry
actually it's hateful and uninformed our
whole life she ain't black enough she
ain't white enough well how about she's
not obedient enough
how about she ain't faithful enough
music is not a color to me it has no
boundaries I sing what I want to sing
be how I want to be
and reach as big an audience as I can
no one is like you you can sing with
Daddy's princess
we're building something here
she just keeps singing Daddy
my money
trusted you do you want me to look out
for me
and down
[Music]
you know YouTube has spent a lot of time
together it's damaging the brand since
the winter little girl become the brand
I missed that
don't even worry about it you're Whitney
Houston
[Music]
[Applause]
love
Millions
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
Shakespeare
reinvented the musical and redefined a
classic comes a bold New Vision of an
American icon but this ain't no
Nostalgia show
we're going to do something different
comical Heroes all find their
superpowers
Elvis found music uh bring that bass up
Jerry I wish to promote you Mr President
I believe I can be great
some people wanted to put me in jail as
Well's moving don't so much as wiggle
the finger almost foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
I would do anything to make sure my mom
and daddy never had to live in poverty
ever again
[Music]
yeah
Colonel you wouldn't end your voice
animal behavior or we will
so much there's a lot of people saying a
lot of things
but in the end you got to listen to
yourself
let me drive and you still want more
I am a promoter that is what I do
is God given so they gave me nothing
wrong with it
[Music]
are you ready to fly I'm ready to fly
Elvis
[Music]
Buzz Lightyear Mission logs Target 3901
after a full year of being marooned our
first hyperspeed test flight is a go who
are you talking uh no one you were
narrating again I was not just doing the
mission log you do know no one ever
listens to them I know that narrating
helps me Focus
ready Captain layer ready as I'll ever
be Commander Hawthorne this is exciting
a new adventure I'm gonna Grant you four
minutes to be off Planet but then you
come right back to us to infinity and
beyond
anywhere clear for hyperlunch
Buzz that was utterly terrifying and I
regret having joined you
Buzz Lightyear Stark man come in Star
Command
why don't they answer
the what what is happening right now
you sure oh no that's my grandmother but
socks how long were we gone Yum Yum Yum
Yum Yum 62 years seven months and five
days what
I hope you're ready for action because
all we needed was a pilot for what to
destroy the alien ship
the plan and I have a team Darby can
take any three things and make him
explode
I do this and they shave a little time
off my sentence okay and what about you
well I thought this was going to be like
a fun boot camp workout thing
but it is not
I need that you know what I'm saying the
harpoon
[Music]
thank you
the probability of survival with an
inexperienced crew is 38.2 percent seems
a bit low
grandma always says she believed in you
too
there was a big swirly dude I think I
need a bag oh no please record your last
words do not vomit inside the vehicle
you're not vomit inside the vehicle if
you are satisfied with this recording
speak or select one
[Music]
to Infinity are you trying to get me to
pull your finger don't fall for it no
not like that sorry it's a thing your
grandma and I used to do yeah
what was that that is an ambulance
that was a car tire
what was that I have no idea what that
was
New York City did we just move here I
think we did you think Josh is going to
be okay
this is my crocodile why please take
good care of him
gosh time to wake up come on
he's not dangerous he's Crocodile he's
just lonely like me hey you awake yet
you can't talk but you can sing at the
top of the world tonight
when no one ever never have to hide
get out of here there's a crocodile in
the house
this could not be happy we have a
crocodile living in her attic
that was totally awesome
the city must do something
do you realize how different things have
been since I met him
foreign
not just for me for YouTube
I've been shaking I love it when you go
crazy
we have to show people that they don't
have to be afraid
we got a crocodile on a motorcycle
there's nothing wrong with you
baby
I've been holding me back
[Music]
my name is alethea
my story is true
I am a solitary creature by Nature
I have no children no siblings nor
parents I did once have a husband
if there is fate who can say
but in the Grand Bazaar of Istanbul I
chose a memento
I like it whatever it is I'm sure it has
an interesting story
[Music]
so what would you wish for what is your
heart's desire
[Music]
I do have a question
what does one do with three wishes
you'll see
[Music]
[Music]
there's no story about wishing that he's
not a cautionary Tale
we'll have a desires even if they remain
hidden from us but it is your story and
I cannot wait to see where it goes
oh how it might end
hello hello he'll be staying for a while
[Music]
I'm beginning to wish we'd never met
save yourself
I have a wish
[Music]
hey look out the window welcome to my
party guys
[Music]
thank you so much for having us this is
my chance to reconnect with the girls
did Mom shoot some space this little
bump right here that's you I still miss
her every day
what's that there's something Crossing
up ahead
stay in the car okay just stay in the
car yeah okay what's he saying devil
I've never seen anything like this
multiple attacks without eating its prey
lives don't do that at least no lion
I've ever seen
[Music]
go back to the calls
Maybe
breathe slow down
we're in his territory now
it's the law of the jungle
it's only law that matters
so they've got guns she's gonna be out
yet
foreign
[Music]
wake up buddy it is walk a clock
maybe I should let him sleep
okay
[Music]
[Music]
we'll go for a walk
I have an owner and the Superman let me
just turn that out and she call me Iron
Man
no my dog's the best but he's not the
greatest with other animals what is new
with you fellow normal dog I bit the
FedEx guy the other day who is he
working for General Zod the Legion of
Doom
FedEx of course the Federation of exes
not to be trusted
what is taking my owner so long
well well well well if it isn't the
Justice League Superman
what's going on
super strong I should be a lot more dead
right now right my best friend is in
danger and you have to help me well
we're just a bunch of shelter pets but
they're stronger than you think the
mighty
[Music]
great I'm the only one who didn't get
any superpowers
when one has an abundance of power
they have a certain duty to use that
power to
sorry you were saying something
how much did you have to drink I had two
toilet bowls end of a day the day two
which is which is crazy I didn't even
know that was a thing but it's like a
dog water fountain
oh out of the way cat child
case deploy canine Shield what is a
canine
made excellent shielding that seemed
incredibly painful
anybody want to switch powers
[Music]
so is this Runway casting for a grumpy
brand or a smiley brand
so it's a grumpy brand yeah
congratulations show me that Balenciaga
look oh suddenly I'm dressed in
something way less expensive
h m yes Balenciaga
and H M
it looks paid for the tickets not better
that's what do you do I sell [ __ ]
the success of a luxury
I don't want to hear anybody saying no
[Music]
it's always yes sir yes ma'am
I command you enjoy the moment
no no no what
you say no to me no no so it's yes yeah
no yes oh yeah yes
the saves you think it's possible to
wash them
I don't think that's possible man
because this is a motorized vessel yeah
so we don't have any sales
yes
well then in that case
we will clean the sails yes of course
yes
[Music]
so loud
[Music]
the Russian capitalist
and an American Communist on a 250
million dollar luxury
thank you
the ship is going under
[Music]
it's really bad
this is really really bad
foreign
[Music]